to my right is bounty law series lead  and Jake Cahill himself  Rick Dalton and to my left is Rick stunt  double cliff booth  so Rick explain to the audience exactly  what it is a stunt double does actors  are required to do a lot of dangerous  stuff cliff here is meant to help carry  load is that how you describe your job  cliff what carrying his load adds about  right  [Music]  my hands are registered as lethal  weapons we get into a fight I  accidentally kill you I go to jail  anybody accidentally kills anybody in a  fight they go to jail  it's called manslaughter  [Music]  [Music]  that was the best acting I've ever seen  in my whole life thank you  [Music]  you